si compramos acciones por 50 dólares
esta es una situación de comprar
acciones es claro que pagan 250 dólares
por anticipado y si éstas llegaran a
subir a 80 dólares si nosotros
lográramos tener una contraparte para
venderlas en 80 dólares generaríamos 30
dólares de ganancias libres de los 50
dólares que invertimos inicialmente
donde esto sería el 60 por ciento de
ganancia si el 60 por ciento sobre
nuestro capital inicial ahora por el
otro lado si las acciones bajarán a 20
dólares nosotros habríamos perdido 30
dólares de los 50 que invertimos por lo
que esto sería perder el 60% por comprar
dichas acciones así bien nosotros
podríamos ganar o perder el 60 por
ciento en este caso y si nos vamos a
extremos de una alza ilimitada
tendríamos mayores ganancias pues las
acciones tienen a cualquier valor
posible y cuando hablamos de bajadas de
la acción
lo que más se podría perder es el 100%
invertido pues en el escenario de la
opción de compra
el hecho de comprarla sólo te cuesta 5
dólares y en el caso de cuando las
acciones llegan a subir a 80 dólares
y nos damos cuenta de que somos capaces
de ganar 15 dólares y esto sería como la
ganancia neta pues al comprar la opción
la inversión fue de 5 dólares y con esto
obtendremos los 15 dólares de ganancia y
si haces cálculos esto sería el 300 por
ciento de ganancia si puedes llegar a
ganar el 300% si la opción sube si el
300%
imagínate suena a una ganancia de spam
pan ante por otro lado si el precio de
la acción baja no tendríamos por qué
ejercer nuestra opción pues
esencialmente sólo se pierde el dinero
invertido en esta que es el 100 por
ciento de los cinco dólares invertidos
pero bueno aquí lo que quiero destacar
es como la opción nos dio apalancamiento
pues una palanca hablando físicamente
nos da un impulso lo que permite tener
mayores frecuencias que en otras
ocasiones y aquí hablando
financieramente una opción de compra
sería la herramienta de apalancamiento
financiero pues si haces esto un siglo
completo sabes que estás multiplicando
tu potencial de ganancias y dejando fija
una perdida pues como mencionamos
anteriormente las alzas pueden alcanzar
cualquier valor
las bajas puedes ejercer o no tu opción
para no perder tanto y hablando en el
buen escenario lo que podría llegar a
ser es el 60 por ciento de ganancia y en
este caso multiplicaríamos nuestra
ganancia en un 300% y por otro lado
cuando las acciones bajan llegaríamos a
perder hasta un 60 por ciento o bien
hasta llegar a perder 100 por ciento de
lo invertido en la opción de compra así
que de esta forma se multiplican las
pérdidas pero sólo en un 100% la
comparación de las ganancias es de 300%
aquí los números ya realmente lucen
favorables pues las ganancias están
multiplicando mucho más que las pérdidas
pero bueno este es un ejemplo con
números que yo escogí en particular
finalmente es lo mismo que apostar que
la acción se va a ir a la alza pero le
estás dando apalancamiento y está
reduciendo tus pérdidas